and we're back now with AK dance from
the ILO the International Labor
Organization so who do you think is
responsible for the shift in investment
greedy investors so the US Federal
Reserve or the emerging markets because
they failed to put their economies on a
more sound footing well many emerging
economies have indeed counted on easy
money from outside to fund their
development and now they figure out that
with change in monetary policy in the
u.s. in japan and south near in the
future also in europe that money is not
as cheap anymore so they have to change
the economies and we only just heard
also that now it's a more
belt-tightening that's needed consumers
should spend less that's not really a
recipe to boost an economy and create
jobs is it on the contrary actually belt
tightening is very difficult in
countries like India or even Argentina
and Turkey where there's a lot of
working poverty still ongoing and
there's just not much to tighten there
now these emerging economies for a long
time they were looked at as a kind of
beacon of hope in the global stormy
weather where are the jobs coming from
now shall we go back to Europe or the US
which are slightly recovered but these
economies need to find their own sources
of growth and the only way to do this is
really to find domestic sources the
private consumption investment in these
economies but it has to come from the
countries themselves then jobs need to
be created in these countries there's
just not enough jobs for for these
people to move to Europe or to move to
the US what about the global labor
market as a whole unemployment I
understand has been rising over the past
few years reaching some 202 million
people out of a job in 2013 where will
this end well the global unemployment
rate is set to increase we see that
global unemployment will reach something
around 215 million in over the next five
years and mostly the jobs are lacking in
emerging economies that's where we need
to create the jobs they have to get out
of this problem right now but again and
thank you very much for joining us